hey youtubers is charlie and last night
and my Walking Dead episode 9 review I
asked you to submit all of your
questions about the episode so now it's
time to answer them and it's time to
crown the winner of my first giveaway
congratulations to Jenna al-sharif in
one of your comments you actually said
you almost cried when you thought Rick
was dead well you can stop crying now
because you just one twenty dollars I'll
be messaging you on your channel for
details but everybody be sure to give
her a high five round two of my giveaway
will start during my episode 10 review
next Sunday if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
that but time for some questions so
number one lily love asks the episode
was a pretty faithful adaptation from
the comic book what other storylines
from the comic book would you want to
see played out in the show so that's
easy i would say the hunters definitely
one hundred percent it was actually one
of my predictions but since they're not
always a hundred percent faithful to the
comic they might merge some of the
characters together there will be a new
villain in the next couple of episodes
even if it's a twist on where the story
in the comic book goes next I hope they
include some aspects from that group
question number two supercharged
chargers desks what do you think about
only seeing Rick Michonne and Carl in
the episode and then in the next episode
only seeing the other group I actually
think that's a really good opportunity
to spend more time on specific
characters the cast is so big that it's
really hard to give characters a lot of
scenes without taking potential scenes
away from others so next week instead of
Rick Carl and Michonne will get you know
Maggie Glenn and everyone else still
crossing my fingers on baby Judith to
question number 392 asks what was up
with me sean's rampage that was just the
pain of what happened at the prison you
know finally getting to her all the
awful things from her past that she had
shut out of her mind just got vomited up
in a hurricane of sword slashes you can
make the argument that just as Carl
tahmid adapter he escaped that pile of
Walker's Michelle vomited up all of her
fields question number four Ben Roycroft
asks do you feel that Rick will survive
until next season or do you think you
will meet his end in the finale I think
of the two big leaders right now Daryl
and Rick Rick will be the first one to
go I know that someone is going to die
before the end of the season but I think
that on the list of people it might be
rick is really low so I do think that
he'll make it to season five they've
already deviated a lot from the comic
book in terms of people that have
already died question number five gijon
a halili asks do you think that baby
Judith is alive yes I do but mostly just
because what would be the reason in not
telling us they really just want to
string it out then
us to wonder whether or not she's alive
by not having her in this episode it
just sweetens the payoff when we finally
do find out Robert Kirkman said that
there would be a definitive answer
really soon so I think in the next
episode we'll find out question number
six Monte Gonzalez asks did me show no
those footprints where Rick and Carl's
as she followed them no she just knew
that they were footprints of someone who
is still alive Walker's typically
dragged their feet along so they
wouldn't have left those clean prints so
I think she was just hoping that they
would have been friends question number
7 z snake asks do you think the terror
will become sort of like me shown after
losing both her niece and her girlfriend
do you think she'd withdraw from really
I'm actually really interested to see
which group they end up with but in
reality i think that lily is the one
that's gonna end up like me show and
remember she killed the governor so
she's pretty hardcore right now i think
she's gonna end up being like me shown
during season three just completely done
to the world question number eight josh
bello asks do you think the carol will
show up by the end I think she'll show
up before the end maybe not next week
but soon I think she'll run into
tyreese's group first and they'll be
like this cloud of weirdness hanging
over them until Tyreese finds out I'm
actually really interested to see if he
reacts the way we expect him to or fee
surprises us and just accepts it right
now my money is definitely on him losing
his [ __ ] though question number 9 jarrel
Mikael asks why does Michonne's 2
zombies never try to attack or bite her
she actually tore their jaws off so they
can't bite her they're literally just
pets she's just keeping them around they
actually used to be two of the
governor's people question number 10
clay sloth asks do you think they will
introduce another antagonist like the
governor yeah everyone's really
wondering if it's gonna be negan but
that is so far ahead in the story I
don't think it's lightly I actually
think it's going to be the new Gareth
character that they've just cast he's
new this season but I think he'll be an
amalgam of the leader from the hunters
and negan or he'll at least be a minor
villain if he doesn't make it to season
five and one more bonus question Kevin
anti-hero asks will they start following
the comic more closely do you think the
remaining survivors will now hit to
Washington DC just because they followed
the comic really closely in this episode
doesn't mean they're gonna you know keep
doing that it always loosely follows the
plot of the comic book but they deviate
quite a bit sometimes I do think that at
least one group will either make it to
Washington DC or make contact with them
I mean the title of the finale this
season is
so everyone's taking that to mean
alexandria thank you so much everyone
for submitting your questions this was a
lot of fun as always since I have a
little extra time this week there's a
lot of TV shows off the air I might do
an extra Walking Dead video before next
week's review if you didn't see it
already I just posted a big break down
to the game of thrones season 4
foreshadowing video you can click here
for that and click here for all my
predictions for the rest of Walking Dead
this season thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight high
fives